major task the biden administration
wants to address to try and streamline
things is with the covet 19 vaccination
process on the federal level
nationwide it's simply been too slow
according to bloomberg
nowhere is it slower than right here in
nevada we are last in the u.s per capita
to get ready to distribute the vaccine
hector maher explains what local health
officials are doing to try and make
improvements
the vaccines are allocated by the state
on a weekly basis the southern nevada
health district here says it's using all
of those resources and working with
community partners such as unlv
to make this vaccine more accessible
right now
health care and public safety workers
are the priority
at vaccination sites appointments are
also available for people
70 years and up however the health
district's website also lists
teachers and other front line workers as
part of the priority group
health officials are asking only those
in the priority group to make an
appointment through their website
appointments are booking fast though
with only a limited supply of the
vaccine arriving each week
and earlier in the week the health
district announced that as of january
11th
almost 29 000 cobin 19 vaccines were
administered
all across the county it's been a little
more than a month
since the very first doses went out and
to date
the health district says it's received
more than 70 thousand doses
for distribution the health district
here says
more dates and times are coming to the
calendar of appointments
so be patient as patient as you can
reporting outside the health district
hector mejia 8 news now
today cashman center's coronavirus
vaccine center is closed
it was shut down a week after a week in
operation so staff could improve how
things go there
the site will reopen on monday with
those improvements in place
at vaccination sites across the valley
officials with the southern nevada
health district are reminding you
you have to make an appointment first
vaccines are also being distributed to
the southern nevada health district
offices
where you just saw hector the encore
resort and smith's pharmacies
we have all the information available at
8newsnow.com